Queen Elizabeth's 97 year old husband
Prince Philip is said to be doing fine
this morning after a car crash where he
was at the wheel his SUV flipped but he
walked away without serious injuries it
happened yesterday near the Queen's
Country Estate in eastern England
Jonathan Vigliotti is at the scene in
Sandringham Jonathan good morning good
morning we may be here in the British
countryside but the road Prince Philip
was trying to turn on to yesterday is
far from some quaint country road we're
talking about three lanes of traffic
travelling up to 60 miles an hour
witnesses say the prince is lucky to be
alive
Prince Phillips Land Rover came to a
screeching halt on its side the force of
impact shattered the windshield and
jolted the 97 year old Prince who was
behind the wheel and strapped into the
driver's seat one way they said Philip
was lightly bleeding and appeared very
shocked but was pulled from the wreck
with the help of a bystander helped you
move his legs which was a bit trapped
crushed and then I saw his face very
nice - it was two women in a second
vehicle were hospitalized with minor
injuries a nine month old baby was found
uninjured in the back seat many people
were surprised to hear Philip was behind
the wheel to begin with Prince Philip is
as we know a very determined headstrong
individual who has wanted to retain a
sense of independence right up until the
age of 97 this is also a man who served
in the Navy who served in the Second
World War a man who has seen action he's
been very active a lot of his life over
the years he's had to dial it back
giving up flying planes and playing polo
in 2017 he retired from his royal duties
driving has remained a source of pride
on display here in 2016 when he drove
the Obamas and his wife Queen Elizabeth
around their home in Windsor I have to
say I have never been driven by a Duke
of Edinburgh before
and Prince Philip is said to be resting
at home the Queen there by his side
Buckingham Palace taking this seriously
and some believe the Prince won't be
allowed to drive on public roads ever
again
Gayle Jonathan Vigliotti outside sound
of mistake thank you know it's not funny
but 97 years old the duke of edinburgh
should maybe hand in his keys